It.
Welcome, Director. And the floor is yours. Thank you.
I feel really short. Okay.
I know. Good afternoon. I'm here to present the FY
23 budget proposal for the Administration and Regulatory
Affairs Department. With me is Val Barry, the CFO
for our department. Next slide, please.
Ara has 18 separate business units.
We're a composite of multiple functional areas
across the city that didn't fit into a single type of department.
And so we have this spread across ten divisions spread across
four different funds. And so we're here to talk about that today.
This slide shows our general fund division. We have
several of our ads and our deputy director here.
The divisions are listed on this slide. The Director's office.
Obviously. Sustainability and Resilience, which is Deputy Director
Priya Zechariah, who is here? Franchise administration.
Valerie Barry, regulatory permitting. Catherine Bruning.
Payroll Services is Karen Davidson, who could not be here today because her husband's
in the hospital. Operations in three one one, which is Charles
Jackson, and Financial Services, which is also Valerie Berry.
One of the things that I want to note before we leave this slide is
I'd like you to draw your attention to the number that you
see before you as our proposed FY 23 budget
of 32.174 million, we round that to 32.2.
However, 10.8 million of that amount is the transfer to
the Bark Special Fund from the general fund. So our actual
budget for the general fund is $21.4 million.
Next slide, please. So the previous
slide showed you our general fund operations. This slide,
as well as the next three will represent the organization charts for the special
funds and the Central Services Revolving Fund that we manage. On this
slide, we show the budget and division breakout for the Park Houston Special
Fund. Park Houston is led by Maria Urshad
and they manage all of the city's on street parking inventory. Next slide,
please. Bark is
the city's animal shelter. It is funded through the Bark Special Revenue Fund.
And it's led by Greg Damienoff, assistant director, who is also here.
The Bark Operational Division includes six sections that administer
all of the programs and services that we provide for Houston's pets and pet
owners. Next slide, please.
The property and casualty fund is a revolving fund
where Ara's risk management division is funded. Risk Management is led
by Tina Paquette, Assistant Director who is also here today. Risk Management
handles all of the commercial insurance for the city of Houston. Next slide,
please. The Central
Services revolving fund is a chargeback fund. You've heard from many of the directors
here today that they run services through the revolving fund. We do
as well. There's no FTEs assigned to this because those are reflected
in other places throughout our budget.
But this is where the costs for the citywide mailroom, the citywide print shop,
citywide payroll services and employee transit are flowed
through. Next slide, please.
And these are the categories of service that Arie provides and the statutory
mandates that require us to provide those services. Next slide,
please. And these are the penalties for
failure to provide the mandated services. Because Ara
is primarily a regulatory department, the majority of our
services are mandated by either federal, state or local ordinances. And the
penalties for nondelvery of those services can be anything from
substantial financial penalties as they are for payroll to even
criminal penalties. Next slide, please.
This slide summarizes our general fund revenues as
well as our special fund revenues. As you can see,
our estimated General Fund revenues for FY 23 will
be down by $1.9 million compared to year
end FY 22, primarily due to franchise
fee decreases. As you can see from this slide, the biggest single
loss will be telephone franchise fees. And these will continue to
drop every year because they're based on the number of landlines in
Houston. And most of us don't use landlines anymore.
We also had a drop in our permitting revenues. This is mainly from alcohol
licenses and taxicab permits. One bright
spot in our revenue picture, even though it's small, is a source of
revenues called Das facilities or network nodes.
With the expansion of 5G, this source of revenue is actually
going up. It produces currently about $2 million a year. There is
a 52% growth in this that's projected for FY 23.
We also administer two special funds the Bark Special Revenue and
the Park Houston Special Revenue Fund. As you can see, we don't
expect much growth in the Bark Special Revenue Fund. This is primarily not an
area that produces revenues. The little bit that we do produce is
in adoption fees, license fees and wellness services. And because
it is so hard to find veterinarians these days, we had another
resignation today. It is very difficult to provide these services.
So our revenues are not expected to come back up in FY 23 for
parking. However, we do have a better story.
Post pandemic. Houstonians are getting back out. They're starting to
park in all of our inner city areas and they're using parking meters.
So this year they're projected to increase by about 7% or 1.3
million. We're also projecting increases in the
revolving funds. Now remember, these are not revenues. These are just paying back
the general Fund for costs. So what you see there in the $1.7
million increase from FY 22 to FY 23 is the
10% increase in the property insurance premiums for the City of Houston. Next slide,
please. On the previous slide,
I showed you all of the individual categories of general fund revenues and
the anticipated decline for FY 23. So I won't go into a
lot of detail on this one because this just provides the narrative for everything
that I just said. But I do want to highlight three things. First is
electricity Revenues CenterPoint remains the highest source of revenues to
the City of Houston, paying us $95 million a year for the use of our
streets. Telephone franchise fees are the second highest fee that
we collect. And as I said, this is a rapidly disappearing
source of franchise fees. At one point it was $60 million. It's down
to $17 million. We can count on that decreasing every budget
year when I'm here. And cable TV franchise fees also
are disappearing because many of us are using Netflix and Hulu and prime, and we're
not using cable TV anymore. So that is also a rapidly disappearing
source of revenue. So the takeaway from this slide is that
between decreasing telephone and cable franchise fees,
you're losing almost $30 million. And that accounts
for $30 million in the general fund budget. Next year. You can expect that to
be much lower.
The next slide, please. On this slide we talk about
more detail related to revenues. Permanent and license revenues, as I
said, had gone down because alcohol establishments were closed during the pandemic.
And that's where we get many of our fees as well as taxicab permits.
Taxicabs had already been decimated by the TNCs.
This pretty effectively eliminated the industry.
And as always, we do attempt to offset our revenue
losses through aggressive auditing and aggressive compliance
efforts. This year, we expect to collect $300,000 in
delinquent revenues just based on those audits.
Next slide, please. And just as I showed
all of the funds that we administer on the revenue slide, this slide summarizes
the expenditures for all of the funds that are administered by Ara.
I highlighted in yellow the row with the general fund expenditures
since I know that's what you're most interested in. And in a few minutes,
when we get to the net change slide, I'll actually walk you through in detailed
that revenue increase of 1.34 million. But for now,
we're going to talk about the special funds. First up is Park Houston.
The increase in expenditures that you see here is
based on two sources. The first is the addition of FTEs for
a new planned fourth shift for compliance.
The second is an increase in the transfer of revenue
to the general fund. As I said before, we didn't
have people parking during the pandemic, so the transfer to the general fund was much
smaller. For FY 23, we were projecting to transfer
$5.5 million from the parking special revenue fund
to the general fund, an increase of $2 million over what we were able
to do this year. The next special fund is Bark. Bark is the
opposite of park. Houston. Rather than transferring money to the general fund,
bark receives money from the general fund. For FY 23,
they'll be receiving 10.8 million. For FY 22, it was
10.5 million. And finally, in the property casualty fund,
you see the increase there. Again, that's an increase in both revenues and expenditures.
It's a flow through fund. Next slide, please.
And this is the graphical representation of the proposed FY 23 general
fund budget. As you can see, the biggest pieces of this budget are
personnel, which is 54% of the budget, or 17.3
million. The second biggest piece is the $10.8 million
transfer to BARC which is 34% of our total expenditure budget. And then
finally, the restricted accounts represent more than half of the 12% that remains
of Ara's General Fund expenditure budget. So only 1.6%
of our total $32.2 million FY 23 proposed
budget is what you might call discretionary meaning that it's not already obligated
to personnel or some sort of contractual or mandated obligation but it's available
for supplies and services. Next slide, please.
This is the same breakdown for the Bark Special Revenue Fund.
Bark's proposed budget is what? 13.3 million.
And as I said before, the lion's share of that is the $10.8 million
transfer from the General Fund in Bark. 67% is
personnel expenses. Next slide piece.
And this is the breakdown for the park houston Special Revenue Fund.
Personnel is 34% of the expenditures of this special revenue fund.
The other big piece of this is 26% which is the transfer
from the Park Houston Special Revenue Fund to the General Fund. Next slide,
please. And this is the breakdown
for Ara's portion of the Property Casualty Service Fund.
Again, this is where our risk management group is funded. You'll notice that
only 3% of this fund goes to pay
for personnel. 97% is insurance premiums for the City
of Houston. Next slide, please.
This is the more complicated slide. There's five blocks here
and we're going to walk through those as quickly as we can while giving you
the detail. Our current budget is broken
out. At the top block, you'll see $17.75 million.
That's our actual FY 22 operating budget. These are
the funds that are available for the General Fund operations of our department.
Added to that amount is the restricted accounts, totally 2.48
million. And then the General Fund transfer to Bark, which is 10.5
million in FY 22. So if you add the restricted items
for FY 22 plus the transfer to Bark,
which was 10.5 the total operating budget that was not available to
Ara and FY 22 was $12.6 million leaving
only the 17.74 million for our operations.
The next block is called Adjustments to FY 22 budget. These are
the amounts that were added or taken out of our budget during the current fiscal
year. And so you have things like the contractual hope,
municipal pay raises and the amount of $283,000 for the General
Fund and $161,000 for Bark. A restricted
accounts adjustment of $71,000.
$21,000 received from Council member Cisneros's Budget Surplus
Fund to fund spay neuter efforts for Bark.
A $17,000 adjustment for scanning services related
to the records retention project at the City Secretary's office which Ara
is managing. And then the last item in the second block is a
$117,000 increase for Bark shelter, cleaning and
a rescue initiative. Those are explained in footnote three.
Altogether, these items yield a net increase from our FY 22
budget of $527,000 bringing the
FY 222 year end adjusted budget to $30.83
million. And then in the next section, you see the operating budget
adjustments that get us to FY 23. These are the amounts that
are added to or reduced from the FY 22 budget to
get us here. So the $21,000.01 time receipt from Council
Member Cisneros from her budget surplus would be subtracted out
in FY 23. You'll also see $216,000
of onetime funds from an FY 22 budget amendment, and the details
of those are spelled out in footnote five. And then in the
third block, you also see $328,000 being added
to fund various one time programs, including the three one one hiring
initiative. And then the details for the $328,000 are
laid out for you in footnote four. And I'll also go through those in just
a second on the next slide. So when you net out the reductions and the
increases in that third block, we end up with a $91,000
net increase to Ara's budget for specific programs
for FY 23. Continuing down the page, we're now
to the fourth block. You see our contractual or mandated adjustments,
and this includes the increases for health benefits, hope,
contractual pay raises, municipal pension costs and restricted
accounts. The total is an increase of $1.25 million
to the Ara budget. And finally, in the fifth block,
we arrive at the proposed FY 23 budget of 32.174
million. And as you can see, the Ara General Fund budget
is increasing by 1.34 million. But of that amount,
only $91,000 is an actual increase to our operating
budget. Everything else is a contractual or mandated amount.
At the bottom block, you have the page that contains the footnotes that detail every
adjustment I just discussed. Next slide, please.
And then this slide summarizes the big picture expenditure changes that we discussed
on the previous slide for the General Fund, as well as the highlights of
our special fund expenditures. So in
addition to the increases for health benefits, pension contribution and municipal
employee contractual pay increases across all funds,
let me reiterate into the general fund the adjustments that are being made are
the $36,000 in one time funding. For the City Secretary records
retention project, the $20,991 in
funding for a hiring incentive to recruit and retain new
three one one agents and $224,861
in resilience funding transferred from the Planning Department to
Ara for the Resilience and Sustainability Office.
For the Bark Special Fund, we received $256,000 for
a shelter cleaning contract, $30,000 for a
rescue incentive program,
$39,000 for the Pep Microchipping Initiative,
and then a reduction of FY 22 non
recurring program adjustments of $563,000.
And finally, for Park Houston,
we received program adjustments funding for ten additional employees to
add a fourth shift of compliance officers. And we realized after we
published this slide that there is an error on the Park Houston bullet.
The amount for the fourth shift is $280,000, and the
slide shows $256,402.
Next slide, please. This concludes our budget
presentation please note that our restricted accounts details, organization charts,
demographics and other relevant materials are included as appendices to
this presentation, including the top three one one service requests for
each one of your council districts. Thank you for your attention.
Thank you, Director.
So, just forward thinking some of your
revenue sources, like cable and television.
We're seeing reduced revenues coming in because
of less usage. So thinking
about the future, what are some creative ideas or ways in which you
think we can generate more revenue? Is there anything in the pipeline
maybe discussed at the state level that you can see that would generate
more revenue through fees? So at the state level,
they have continued to erode our fees. For example, when they took away
TNCs, that would have been a $70 million revenue by now.
Network nodes by now would have been $40
million revenue. But that was also decimated at the state level.
It's still a growing revenue, but by no means the size that it would have
been. And so what the mayor charged us with was finding
anything in the right of way that we were not charging fees for already,
because again, it belongs to the public and the public should be reimbursed for it.
And that's what we've tasked our group to do. We're speaking to public works about
what things that they are charging permitting fees for that should actually be rental
because the city charter does call for uses in the right of way to
be reimbursed as rental rather than permit fees. Thank you,
Council Member Amy Pick. Thank you, Vice Chair.
And thank you, Director, for the presentation. Can you talk a little bit
more about three one one and anything that might be in the budget to
fix the three one one app and the three one system this next fiscal
year? I'm very glad you brought that up because we
are completely expecting that by the end of the year we'll have
a new app. When we rolled out the new three one
one system, we were excited about it because it has all kinds of really cool
functionality if you're at your desktop. And we thought that what
most people wanted, based on the customer feedback that we'd gotten, was to be able
to figure out what the status of their service request was. That was the single
biggest complaint we got under the old system. And when you use the old app,
it changed the number of your service request. By the time you got
to the actual system and went into the web to check it,
everybody was angry about that. So we thought what we're going to do instead is
optimize the desktop app for mobile and then everyone will
have all the information they want. And what we didn't realize was that what customers
also wanted to do was take pictures and be able to drop a GIS pin.
So the new app is going to have the best features of
all of that. We're going back to Cclick Fix, which was the app we used
before, but we're enhancing it now so that it has a lot of the neat
functional features that we added to the desktop app.
And it will also include the neat things about picture taking in GIS.
And that will be out before the end of the year. So how much money
did we spend on going to this new three one one app?
And are we just out that money that we spent transferring over
and then going back? So the new app was actually in the original development
cost of the whole system. It wasn't a separate cost.
It actually was not something that was very hard for Accenture to do because all
that they did was optimize the desktop app. So that wasn't a
cost. And it's not a matter of recouping that there is a cost to the
new app that's coming up and there will be a new contract that Hits will
actually be bringing to you to approve and vet. Okay,
thank you. Council member Abby Cayman.
Hi, Director. First off, to all
of your divisions. I don't know how Ara encompasses
so much. It's truly extraordinary. But my
staff just did a tour of three one one, and I cannot thank
the operators enough there. The retention, the knowledge
that they have is extraordinary. Bark I
know that times have been really challenging. I think you just mentioned we
just lost another veterinarian.
What are we trying to do to recruit right now other than financial
incentives for veterinarians? I know that has been an issue even
before coming into office, and I know I even talked to veterinarian
offices around the city, or at least in my district.
Same thing. It's hard right now. What else are we looking
at in terms of that right now? It's a national shortage.
So what we used to do was regularly just go around the country and
poach. And now most veterinarians who are graduating
do not want to do shelter medicine. If they're going to do
veterinary medicine at all, they want to work in a private practice where they get
to use the cool new technology and do a lot of diagnostics spaying
and neutering. Not the most fun thing to do. So it's hard.
One of the things that we'd like to do is start an internship program with
one of the universities, and Council member Cisnero's led an effort toward that.
We haven't gotten much traction with A and M, honestly,
but now we're looking at going national with any other vet school that's willing to
partner with us. And we would find a way to pay for their interns that
come here, even if it's through private funding. But we're working with best friends and
some of our other partners locally to try to troubleshoot that. And I appreciate
the partnership with outside organizations. I also wanted to give
a huge shout out to parking.
Incredible job, especially dealing with a lot of the challenges that we face
inside the District and obviously the Office of Resiliency and Sustainability,
that's going to be monumental and historic work that's taking place
there. Two quick questions. Three quick questions.
One, scanning for all of
our records and archiving, is that really happening? That's really
happening. The mayor asked us last
year or the year before to go over to city secretary's office and at least
start boxing everything up to get it organized. And we did that, and she has
been so welcoming to us and working with us on that. And then he gave
us money to start the scanning project. We're actually working with the
state of Texas. They have someone who archives all of their records,
and we're sending up 100 boxes at a time to get them scanned and
make them searchable. Because remember, there's no point in having them just be PDFs.
They need to be searchable PDFs. Okay. And do we have a timeline,
estimated timeline for completion on that? The mayor wants it done
before he leaves. Okay, understood.
Can I be placed back in queue, please?
You're back in the queue now. All right,
director, one thing I wanted to bring up, and I'm
happy to talk offline about it, but last year council did
pass an amendment that I drafted related to and first off,
thank you to the department for all of the work on the sound ordinance changes
thus far. Sally is like, yes, huge victory.
There was one other thing we had asked the department to look at, which is
weekend hours as it relates to construction. Right now,
there's no distinction between weekday and weekends.
We're getting construction 07:00 a.m. Saturdays and Sundays,
and residents need a reprieve.
Again, we had set a timeline for the end of this fiscal year,
and I know it's coming up, so I just wanted to check on
the status of that. If you all are ready to proceed with stakeholder meetings
on that and what we can do. We have
not even begun that the changes to the noise ordinance that we made
took so much longer than anyone anticipated they were going to make with stakeholders
that we put this on the back burner because, remember, it was a whole different
group of stakeholders than restaurants and everyone else. So that's something I have
to circle back with with the mayor and ask him if we can now start
having those stakeholder meetings for that. Okay. If we could talk offline about that
and just come up with kind of a plan of attack, our residents
would really appreciate it. And then lastly, you've addressed
a lot of needs. Is there anything else that you want to mention
to us that we need to be aware of in terms of upcoming needs in
the foreseeable future, given how tight this budget is?
So you've been asking every department that question.
So we thought a lot about it. And the mayor has been very good about
giving one time money where it was needed. For example, for our hiring initiative for
three one one. By the way, our turnaround time right now, our average speed of
Anderson for three one one is consistently less than a minute. So you should be
very happy to hear that. But our biggest need is
embark. We can't keep people, we can't hire people. We consistently
have between a 20% to 35% vacancy in
that division. And it's not even an animal enforcement officers,
believe it or not. We can keep those. It's the people who clean the shelter
every day. So the mayor said, well, okay, if we don't have enough people to
keep the shelter clean and then also be able to feed and water
and treat the animals, let's get a cleaning contract in there and get some
contractors in to clean it to free up the employees. We did that and you
see the money here for it. The first week they showed up,
they came with four people and three of them left and said, this is not
my gig. I'm not doing this. So we're still troubleshooting that,
but our single biggest need is people.
Understood? Thank you. And again, thank you to the there's a lot of people back
there. Thank you all for everything that you do.
Yeah, you want to have your team stand up in the back so we can
say hello and thank you.
Thank you all for everything that you do.
We know you make the most out of a little and we appreciate all
your efforts, all the engagement with our offices and look forward
to working with you in the days ahead. So thank you, Director and Ms.
Barry for your presentation. And you are dismissed. Thank you,
sir. We'll now move to the public comment period.
We'll start with the virtual public speakers. Please press star six to
unmute when you hear your name. First name is Amanda
she.
Hello. Thank you.
Does Ara or any other department do analysis on
the three one one calls to identify broad or persistent
gaps in service delivery?
That's a great question. I would like to know the answer to
that myself. We will respond to that question
within 48 hours. So if you want to, please send that over to
District E at houstontx Gov, we'll get a
response for you. Do you
have any other questions, Ms. She?
No, I do not. Thank you. Thank you. Saba Blanding.
Hi. I know staff has already been discussed.
I was just curious if there were any additional financial resources Bark
needed to address Houston's stray population.
I'm sure additional resources are greatly needed and appreciated.
Many of our offices use our council district service funds to also
put through projects to work with Bark and Houston Humane Society for spay
and neuter programs. So if you want to reach out to
your district council member on ways in which to understand
the money that they may be allocating or any of the eleven district council
members. We'll be able to provide that information to you. But pretty regularly around
the city of Houston, the District council members are putting forth
spay and neuter programs for the public to take
notice of and be a part of. Thank you.
You're welcome. Jason Oliver.
My first question follows up on Amanda.
I definitely am interested in the three one one analysis.
I'd also like to know about what other performance measures Ara
has for three one one call. Answering time is
important and as it shows, there's major
room for improvement. But I'd also like to know just see more
metrics around the service, around service delivery. And then
second harkening
back to fleet management metrics. The city consistently uses
around 10 million gallons of fuel every year. Where does fuel reduction
show up in the city's sustainability plans? And how are we doing
with that?
Council Member David Robinson. Mr. Oliver, another great question from
you about our fuel goals.
That the reduction of our
reliance on both petroleum gas products
is in both our Climate Action Plan as
well as the Resilient Houston plan. The exact section and
reference and goals are outlined
in that. So I again commend you for the good question.
We can help you locate that if you're unaware of that or otherwise
get an update for you about the current status of attaining
those goals. Thanks for the question.
Thank you. I'll check the reports and see what we've got.
There are no additional public speakers. And this concludes our Administrative and Regulatory
Affairs budget workshop. We will now move to begin
our budget workshop for municipal courts.
I believe that we had other speakers in the audience who
signed up. They were on the list emailed to us.
Good catch.
Our first in person public speaker is Meredith
Powell. Meredith Powell.
Luckily, Amy recognizes me.
Thank you. Ms. Powell, the floor is yours. Thank you. Good afternoon,
council members. My name is Meredith Powell. I live in district a
by profession. I'm a communications and community relations consultant.
I'm also the president of my neighborhood association, so Council member Peck
and her staff hear from me regularly. I'm very
passionate about animal welfare issues and I recognize the
role for Bark. I'm not one of those people who's like Bark is bad and
all of that kind of stuff. I'm here to encourage you all,
whether it is within your own districts or
as a council, to increase resources as much as possible for Bark.
Because thousands
of animals live on the street and need rescuing. And while there are many rescue
groups and street rescuers like myself, we can only do so much.
I work with Rpm and straight out of Texas to transport animals as
much as possible. But I encourage you to give as many resources to
Bark. Because if we don't give resources to Bark and animal. Control.
It just exacerbates the problem that we're having because we have
stray animals on the street that are not fixed.
And it's just creating even more of a population that we're dealing with.
So one of the things I wanted to raise
is when we do the transport rescues, many of the people in other states
ask, what is the problem with Houston? What is the city doing about it?
And it makes us look really bad. I mean, Houston's leader in energy,
space exploration, health care, all of these different things.
Yet we get questions about what is the leadership position that
Houston is taking to deal with the animal welfare issues.
So I know we're working on microchip laws and I applaud city
council and the city of doing those kind of things and stray and neuter efforts.
I just encourage you to continue to provide resources to Bark
to address our city's ongoing animal issue.
Thank you. Are there some specific areas within Bark
that you think the dollars would be most best utilized for?
I mean, sometimes I see programs that I don't think make sense. I understand
when we want to offer adoptions at low rates, but we
also have to ensure that people who adopt at lower cost have the resources
to pay for the animals, because then what happens is animal turnins or
they release them as strays. So that's an issue. I think there's
an opportunity for better public private partnership.
We do so much with our theater district and sports and all of these areas
where we have these huge companies who are supporting our efforts within the city.
We don't really see that within Bark and animal control. I think that that's
an opportunity. Great suggestion.
Council member Amy Peck. Thank you, Meredith, for speaking
today. And I just wanted to thank you for all the work that you do,
especially in District A, when it comes to the animal population.
She is constantly out there rescuing
stray pets and doing so much work. So I just wanted to thank you for
that and for coming today. Thank you. Council Member Abby Cayman
I also just wanted to thank you for your efforts with Rescued Pets movement.
I know we've partnered in our office with them in the efforts.
My mom's even volunteering now. Really just amazing
and beautiful work. I think your point about public private partnerships
is dead on. And even including I
was thinking, especially with the veterinarian shortage, how do we tap
into the vet services that we already have in the city and that infrastructure and
getting volunteers and things like that. So all that's
to say, thank you. I really appreciate it. And I know Council
Member Peck really respects and appreciates all the work that you do in the district.
Thank you. And I encourage you to continue to reach out to Council
Member Peck and any of us if you have any specific ideas.
I know as the presentation was stated, that the mayor has
a commitment to sometimes put one time funding sources towards
specific needs with bark. And they still sometimes have challenges
with recruitment, with retaining and with getting some of the services done.
But any ideas? A person like yourself who has vast experience
and understanding of the infrastructure of that entity
would be greatly appreciated. Thank you so much. You're welcome.
Are there any in person public speakers who
would like to come forward?
Well, now, this concludes our Administrative and Regulatory Affairs
budget workshop.